what is up everybody it's anna mack here
for anime uproar and after five freaking
years of theories and debates and
mystery the ua traitor was finally
revealed and yes we all knew it it was
deku's mom all along okay not really but
it is one of the class 1a students and
this is absolutely crazy the mha manga
is so hype right now and tension and
suspense just keeps growing so let's get
into it if you guys enjoy our mha
content and you want to see more you
know what to do just leave a quick like
and comment it only takes a second but
it helps with the youtube algorithm and
if you want a completely free way to
directly support the channel just take
the time to hit that subscribe button
and then also hit the bell to turn on
all notifications i know it seems like a
little thing but here on youtube that
means a lot finally this video will of
course contain boku no hero manga
spoilers so please proceed with caution
you have been warned so in chapter
335 the one that seemingly reveals the
traitor we start things off back at the
ua grounds with all might and the class
1a students discussing their strategy to
defeat the villains all might explains
that even though they unfortunately lost
stars and stripes according to the
pilots when shigaraki stole a new order
the quirk became like a poison to him
and it started destroying him from
within in fact not only was new order
hurting his body but it also destroyed a
bunch of the quirks that had stockpiled
inside of him this is an important piece
of information it's hard to say how many
quirks shigaraki still has left inside
of him but some of these quirks may have
been lost forever that said i have to
caution that all for one might have
copies of these quirks stored away
somewhere because we know that he and
ujico figured out a way to copy quirks
so despite what all might said we can't
assume that all the quirks he lost
because of new order really will be lost
forever it's possible that he won't be
able to get some of them back but you
never know whether he has them backed up
on the cloud or whatever anyway at this
moment the heroes are using the extra
time they got from stars and stripes to
sacrifice to help get as many people to
safety as possible they are trying to
evacuate civilians rescue anyone who has
been injured due to all of this villain
activity and in general they are trying
to get everyone out of harm's way before
another major battle breaks out that
said all might knows that it will be
hard to predict the actions of offer one
and shigeraki especially when they are
badly injured whatever happens whether
they find the villains first or whether
the villains attack them first an
all-out war is inevitable all might then
outlines their biggest targets and of
course the villains who pose the biggest
threat to all of them this includes all
for one and shiguraki in shigaraki's
body all for one in his real body dobby
toga the remaining high ends and the
remnants of the paranormal liberation
front these are the people that they
really need to watch out for but in the
meantime they have to take down all of
those escaped prisoners who are causing
chaos all over japan and who are acting
on all for one's orders since they don't
know where alpha-1 and chicago are at
this moment they have to do as much as
they can to weaken the villains before
the final battle happens that means
taking down these escaped convicts one
by one before they can join up with all
for one and support him in the final
battle that is going to be a difficult
and time-consuming mission but it makes
sense every villain that they leave on
the streets now will end up fighting
them during the final showdown almight
also warns that yet more threats are
sure to arise and the heroes themselves
are nowhere near as strong as they were
before apparently the heroes lost more
than half of the forces they had back in
the previous battle the battle of jakku
and i think this refers to the heroes
who died the heroes who were injured and
then also the heroes who retired all my
tells class 1a that they must protect
themselves and everyone they hold dear
and bakugo just kind of screams at him
like what do you think we've been doing
this whole time old man we then learned
that class 1a is now continuing their
training with the wild wild pussycats
presumably within the confines of the ua
campus and all of class 1a declared that
they will fight by deku's side until
shigaraki has been defeated yup all of
class 1a every single one of them
definitely no asterisk deku tells
everyone that bakugo promised to train
with him in order to help him master one
for all and after throwing another one
of his trademark freakouts baku explains
that he has a new technique called
cluster that he wants to test out
against someone with one for all if it
works against someone who has a quirk as
strong as one for all then it will also
work against the villains meanwhile we
see that all might is quite hurt by the
loss of stars and stripes but he is also
hopeful about his fledglings the young
heroes of class 1a they started out as
inexperienced little eggs but those eggs
have now hatched into formidable heroes
all might declares that all for one has
done something very foolish because
class 1a is strong
what is this foolish thing that all for
one has done in relation to class 1a
i'll get back to that in a little bit
because the chapter then takes us to all
for one's current hideout where his real
body shigaraki toga dobby and spinner
are currently located despite getting
rid of new order shigaraki is still in
immense pain but the real all for one
tells him that he will be fine all for
one says that as long as they bide their
time they will be able to use their
quirks again this kind of implies that
once shigaraki's body recovers all for
one may be able to transfer copies of
the quirks he lost back into his body
which would kind of take away from
america chan's big sacrifice but we'll
have to wait and see what happens
shigaraki then goes into this raging
rant about hating all might and how he
wants to make sure that not a single
person remembers all might and honestly
i can't really relate to this obsession
with all might i guess the confrontation
with stars and stripes reminded him of
all might's enduring legacy but like the
man is long retired and you have bigger
problems to worry about all for one
tries to comfort shigaraki by explaining
that even though they weren't able to
effectively steal new order and use it
for themselves they were able to remove
their greatest obstacle which was stars
and stripes herself as i said many times
before if america chan had successfully
joined up with the japanese heroes the
final battle would have been much much
harder for the villains that is why all
for one took that giant risk of
confronting her and even though he also
took some damage in the end it was
definitely a favorable outcome for him
all for once says that even though he
has carefully prepared everything they
still have to wait a little while longer
before they act presumably they have to
wait for shigaraki to recover from his
current severe injuries dobby doesn't
like this idea because he's itching to
confront his father again but that's
when all for one explains the difference
between the two of them they are both
dangerous villains who want revenge and
they've both been pursuing one single
goal for pretty much their entire adult
lives however all for one has many
different plans and backup plans a bunch
of different routes that all converge at
the same goal so even if one of his
plans falls through he still has a plan
b and c and d and so on he is prepared
for all eventualities and he always has
a trick up his sleeve and what is that
trick you might ask all for once says
that unlike dobby aka toya all for one
has a lot of friends and then we see
that final page
on the very page that we see the speech
bubble of all for one saying i have a
lot of friends we see none other than
class 1a student toru hagakure well we
see her gloves and the rough outline of
her body but you know what i mean the
text on this final page reads a shocking
reveal is the traitor really color
spread next week whoa the ua trader was
seemingly finally revealed and it is the
invisible girl toru hagakure i mean the
only way that toru isn't the traitor now
is if horikoshi is deliberately tricking
us and then in the next chapter we see
that toto was actually being set up by
someone else like say deku's mom but
that's probably unlikely so for now we
just have to assume that toru really is
the traitor and that is actually crazy
although not completely unexpected and
i'll explain why but first i just want
to say that if you've been following
this channel lately then you know that
i've been saying over and over again
that the ua trader plot point will
return to the manga soon because the
traitor will be the one who will help
the villains get past the new ua
security system so i'm actually really
happy to see my suspicions were proven
to be correct horikoshi did not forget
about this plot point as some people
wanted to argue but he was saving it for
the final act of the story and for the
final epic showdown let's freaking go
now about toto specifically she was
actually one of the earliest ua trader
suspects and shout out to fellow
youtuber joyboy theories who made a
video about toto being the traitor four
and a half years ago i will link that
video in the description that is a pro
gamer move right there okay so let's
look back at some of the evidence that
we had for toru being the trader and why
she was one of the first suspects i
won't spend too much time on this but
just real quickly obviously the fact
that she is invisible makes it difficult
to determine what she's doing at any
given time which makes her the perfect
trader also being part of class 1a means
she can keep an eye on all the most
important players at ua during the
villain attack on the usj toto's exact
location is conspicuously unknown she
claimed that she was transported to the
landslide area but that's the same area
that todoroki was transported to and he
used his quirk to basically freeze the
entire area as soon as he got there
todoroki didn't seem to notice toto
there meaning that if he just started
freezing everything around him he likely
would have frozen at least a part of her
so people were suspecting that she was
lying about her location because she was
the one who helped the villains
infiltrate the usj on top of that toto
was the person who first suggested that
class 1a students should go visit a
shopping mall together and on that same
day in that exact same mall shigaraki
just happened to show up and confront
deku it's almost as if shigaraki knew
exactly where deku would be and when the
other thing about toru is that we know
almost nothing about her background and
her family which allows horikoshi to
fill in the blanks later and explain how
she became the traitor that said things
could be more complicated than we
realize like yes she could just be a
villain who is secretly committed to all
for one's cause and has been all this
time and her family might even be a fake
family that offer one created to trick
the ua staff but something else could be
going on too for example all for one
could be blackmailing toto in some way
maybe even by threatening the safety of
her parents or other loved ones if she's
the traitor only because she's being
blackmailed then we might see some
interesting character drama and she
could be redeemable in the end if she
decides to betray all for one but if she
is a committed villain then i look
forward to learning her backstory and
motivations honestly i'm fine with
either scenario i just want it to make
sense and i want toto's motivations to
be interesting and compelling either way
i am so glad that this plot point is
back and i'm honestly super excited to
see where this goes from here and
remember earlier in the video when i
talked about all might saying that all
for one has done something foolish in
relation to class 1a do you think that
all might was just referring to
something generic like all for one
underestimating the students or do you
think that all might might know about
the traitor is it possible that toru
already came clean to him at some point
in the past or that he figured out what
was going on but he's waiting to reveal
it because he wants to feed bad intel to
the villains through toru when all might
says this it really felt like he knew
something that we don't i don't think
that the rest of class 1a knows anything
about the traitor but something else
could be going on here and i honestly
can't wait to see what this is all about
let me know what you guys thought of
this hype traitor reveal after like five
years of waiting for it is toru really
the ua trader and if so is she doing it
because she's a villain or because she's
being blackmailed in some way does all
might know about the trader already and
is he planning to use that information
to get one over on all for one and what
about the class 1a students how will
they all react to this crazy turn of
events definitely share your thoughts
down in the comments below we absolutely
need to get a massive conversation going
about all of this if you guys enjoyed
this video and you want to see more boku
no hero content right here on the
channel please leave a like to let me
know it only takes a second but it helps
a lot and if you haven't subscribed to
the channel already do me a quick favor
and click that subscribe button and then
also hit the bell and select the option
that says all if you don't do that
you're still going to miss a ton of our
videos even if you are subscribed it's
just how youtube works you can also hit
me up on twitter and instagram at
animeopror i wanna give a big thank you
to all of our anime opera patrons who
make videos like this one possible
special thank you to alpha sigma this
man is an absolute mad lad and a
disciple of lord twego himself and i
can't forget all of our the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including ingrata aljatol
pate heffa the red-haired fox hinokami
and water the toasted chi corey mcgowan
the spike dylan isidore spidey liftinel
tungsten tarkis baked buddhist monkey d
quilly cody hebert and jeremy cummings
finally thank you also to our pro hero
tier patrons including the one and only
gilgamesh steelers angel cruz very gucci
alicia octor bonnie parks joy and garcia
fat boy games kaido might be a duck
jessica rabbit and jeremy phillips if
you enjoy our videos and you feel that
they provide value to you consider
supporting us on patreon even a single
dollar will give you access to our
patron exclusive discord and your name
will appear in our videos along with
these legendary people as always thank
you guys so much for watching and until
next time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you